the Irving G Thalberg award unlike our
friend Oscar is not given for one film
but rather it's given to a producer for
consistent high quality over a number of
films basically that means putting every
dollar up there on the screen where it
can't never cheating never cheating the
audience the recipient of the Thalberg
world this evening is a man who has done
just that of course I may speak with a
little prejudice but I do speak with
first-hand knowledge because he's been
paying my rent and contributing towards
the kids school fees since 1973 Albert R
broccoli who is known from gateman two
front offices cubby started life as the
son of an Italian immigrant farmer who
introduced to America a vegetable that
bore the family name and in turn that
son that son cubby introduced a number
to the screen but none of us will ever
forget double-o for I mean
double-oh-seven spicen are perfect
leaving the family farm at an early age
cubby ended films as a mail boy at 20th
Century Fox from farm to Fox he became
an assistant director and after learning
his trade teamed with Irving Allen to
produce films like paratroopers
cockleshell heroes fired on below the
trials of Oscar Wilde he also produced
the delightful children's classic Chitty
Chitty Bang Bang then 21 years ago he
formed a partnership with Harry Saltzman
to make a picture based on a novel by
Ian Fleming to star a relatively unknown
actor at that time named Sean Connery
the film of course was dr. know and so
began a golden chain of 12 films which
have been seen by more than one and one
quarter billion moviegoers around the
world and from that first James Bond
adventure that drove escapism beyond the
larger-than-life screen entertainment of
the past kabir broccolis vivid
imagination has surged constantly higher
producing the longest continuous string
of successful motion pictures in the
history of the art form
says for all life sonic achievement
through films thanks Cuse me Thank You
Roger for this marvelous award it's
tremendous honor to be recognized by the
Academy and I'm grateful to his Board of
Governors a selective named the Irving G
Thalberg award I never dreamed when they
came to Hollywood 1934 that I'd be
standing here to receive an award from a
man who was the idol for us this is an
important one of my life I feel a great
sense of accomplishment not only for
myself but all my colleagues with whom
I've worked over the years the actors
the writers the directors those
exceptionally dedicated and devoted
technicians at Pinewood Studios in Great
Britain and for my associates at United
Artists the particular I'd like to
acknowledge two men who were my first
producing partners the first presenting
Alan together we enjoyed making the
films that Roger Moore mentioned the
second was my partner former partner
Harry Saltzman
who also envisage the possible success
of James Bond and together we received
the go-ahead from a very different
demand Arthur Krim without Arthur I
would not be standing here tonight at
this highest point of my career and I
thank him and I thank the Academy for
allowing a farm boy from Long Island to
realize this dream